homicide life on the streets in Brooklyn
99 Star Andre Brower passed away on
December 11th at the age of just 61 now
we know the late actor's cause of death
and it's caught many by surprise The
Hollywood Reporter broke the news that
Brower died of lung cancer with previous
reports of his sudden death stating that
the star experienced what his
representative called a brief illness
the New York Times followed that up by
reporting that Brower was diagnosed with
lung cancer a few months ago a 2014
times profile Brower noted that the
actor had stopped smoking years earlier
the entertainment industry was left
shocked and saddened by brower's passing
his colleagues on Brooklyn 99 released
statements honoring their friend and
co-star and other Hollywood figures
Express deep grief over the abrupt loss
the two-time Emmy winner and prolific
performer of both stage and screen was
known for his deep lyrical voice his
roles as authority figures and
extraordinary Talent Brower is survived
by his wife Amy brabson whom he met
while working on homicide life on the
street their three sons Michael Isaiah
and John Wesley brower's mother Sally
Brower and his brother Charles Jennings
after earning acting degrees from
Stanford University and the Julie Art
School Brower made his film debut in
1989 alongside Denzel Washington in the
drama Glory but it was his role as
detective Frank pembleton on homicide
life on the street that made him a
household star more recent audiences
likely know Brower best for playing the
trailblazing deadpan police captain
Raymond Holt on Brooklyn 99 Hol led a
quirky gang of detectives and officers
in the New York City burough in the
pilot it's revealed that Holt had a
difficult career in the NYPD because
he's an open League G black man after he
takes over the 99th Precinct the
detectives including Andy samberg's Jake
Peralta and Melissa fero's Amy Santiago
quickly bring him into the fold whether
Hol was awkwardly pretending to be a
straight man or flying off the handle
mid interrogation about the differences
between dentists and doctors Brower made
every single line reading on Brooklyn 99
sing I know we live in a world where
anything can mean anything and nobody
even cares
about apparently that's a trigger for me
as his time on Brook Glen 99 came to a
close Brower told variety he wanted to
spend more time with his family but
clearly his intention was not to retire
at the time of his death the actor had
taken on a major part in a buzzy
upcoming series his death now leaves the
fate of its release seriously in
question the series is the residence a
murder mystery drama produced by
legendary showrunner Shonda Rimes as
part of her ongoing deal with Netflix
the show had already shut down
production during the SAG after strike
which started mid July and lasted
through early November according to a
deadline report only four episodes shot
before brower's passing so not only are
the show's creators and cast mourning
the loss of their colleague but there's
no word on how or if the series could
work without Brower the Brooklyn 99
standout was set to Star as white house
chief Usher AB winter he was set to Star
alongside Orange is the New Black Star
uzo aduba who portrays a detective
tasked was solving a murder that takes
place during a state dinner at the White
House as of the making of this video
producers have provided no information
about how or if the residents will move
forward Brower could be replaced with
another talented actor but it's
devastating that the world missed out on
yet another brilliant turn from him
perhaps production will find a way to
use Brower scenes to honor his memory
and
work